السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا محمد مزيمز
لنتابع معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
ولكن بايجاز وضمنا ابرز الاحداث
اشتباكاتنا مسلحه في السودان ومطالب
اغاثيه اعتقال رئيس حركه النهضه الغنوشي
ترحيل لاجئين السوريين قصرا من لبنان
اذا نبدا من السودان الذي يشهد منذ نحو
ثلاثه اسابيع اشتباكات مسلحه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيث اشتدت
المعارك في الخرطوم وان درمان ودارفور رغم
سريان الهدنه الخامسه التي اعلنها الطرفان
وسط موجه نزوح وهجره واسعه يعيشها السودان
منذ بدء المواجهات في حين تستمر عمليه
وجلاء لرعايه الدول العربيه والاجنبيه من
السودان الاشتباكات فاقمت الاوضاع الصحيه
والمعيشيه الصعبه اصلا اذ توقف العديد من
المستشفيات في مناطق المواجهات عن ذلك
نساله مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت من الخرطوم
مرحبا هيثم
كيف تبدو الاوضاع لديك حتى اللحظه تحديات
عديده تواجه القطاع الصحي والجانب المعيشي
في الخرطوم نتيجه لاستمرار هذه المعارك
والتي تدخل اسبوعها الثالثه الان هذه
المعارك انعكست سلبا على حياه الناس ضعف
القطاع الصحي وتدهور المؤسسات الصحيه
والتعرف بعضها للقصف وايضا عدم وجود
المقدره الشرائيه للمواطنين كي يحصلوا على
المواد الغذائيه لقله النقود وايضا عدم
وجود المتاجر الكافيه في كثير من المواقع
سواء كان هنا في العاصمه الخرطوم او حتى
في الاماكن الاخرى المتضرره جراء هذا
الصراع شكرا جزيلا لك هيثم يعتقل الامن
التونسي رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
بعد مداهمه منزله قبل ان تامر المحكمه
الابتدائيه في العاصمه تونس بايداعه السجن
على خلفيه تصريحات اعتبرتها النيابه
العموميه تحريضيه وبانها تهدد الامن
القومي في حين طالبت شخصيات عربيه واجنبيه
باطلاق سراح الغنوشي ودعت جبهه الخلاص
انصارها للاحتجاج بالعاصمه للمطالبه
باطلاق سراح الموقوفين اعتقال الغنوشي لقي
صدى داخليا وخارجيا نتوجه الى ضيفنا
الكاتب الصحفي التونسي والخبير بالحركات
الاسلاميه صلاح الدين الجورشي
مرحبا السيد صلاح الدين
برايك ما هي تبعات اعتقال الغنوشي على
مسار الحركات المعارضه في تونس
اعتقال رشد الغنوشي له تداعيات كبيره
سلبيه على النظام وكذلك على الوسط السياسي
بشكل عام هذا الاعتقال لم يكن مبررا لا
يوجد تناسب بين ما ذكره وبين التهم
الخطيره ذات له
ووجد نفسه من النظام عاجزا ان يقنع الراي
العام الدولي وكذلك المنظمات الحقيقيه
والحكومات الغربيه في جدوى هذا الاعتقاد
من ناحيه الثانيه مثلا الاعتقاد اعطى فرصه
الغنوشي لكي يستعيد مكانته ودوره حيث
تقريبا معظم الاطراف تنظر اليه بشكل
ايجابي واعتبر وطلبت في اطلاق سراحه مما
جعل حتى معارضيه في الداخل
يتراجعون ويقفون انتقاداته السابقه بما في
ذلك ابناء حركه النهضه شكرا جزيلا لك
السيد صلاح الدين الى لبنان وجد لي ترحيل
اللاجئين السوريين اذ دعت منظمه والعفو
الدوليه السلطات اللبنانيه الى وقف عمليات
الترحيل غير القانونيه للاجئين السوريين
خشيه ان يتعرضوا لتعذيب او اضطهاد عند
عودتهم الى بلدهم تاتي الدعوه بعد ترحيل
السلطات اللبنانيه حوالي خمسين سوريا
القرار اثار جدلا على منصات التواصل لنقرا
لكم مشاهدينا بعضا من تغريداتكم نبدا مع
لوريلا التي تقول قصه اللاجئين السوريين
مش قصه اقتصاديه ولا قصه امن وامان وبس
صارت قصه وجود ومستقبل اما وائل العنيزي
فيقول نحترم سياده الدوله اللبنانيه وهذا
حق مشروع لهم انهم يرحلون من على اراضيهم
ويبقوا
على من يريدون ولكن اطرحلونهم الى جلادهم
بشار يتساءل يقول هم استجاروا بكم من بشار
واجرامه وتقومون بتسليمهم الى بشار
الى تركيا وسباق الانتخابات حيث بدا
الناخبون الاتراك في الخارج بالتوجه الى
صناديق الاقتراع للادلاء باصواتهم في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه وذلك عند
البوابات هي الجمركيه والبعثات والممثليات
التركيه ويستمر ذلك حتى الرابع عشر من
مايو المقبل يتنافس على منصب الرئاسه
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان مرشحا عن
تحالف الشعب وعن التحالفي الامه كمال
لاكستار اوغلو اضافه الى محرم انجه رئيسي
حزب البلد وسنان اوغان مرشحا عن تحالف
اللجنه في خبرنا الاخير وقبل ثواني من
هبوطها على سطح القمر الاتصال انقطع بين
المهمه القمريه الاماراتيه راشد والقاعده
الارضيه بحسب شركه اي سبيس اليابانيه
المشغله للمهمه لم تنجح محاولات المهندسين
المختصين اعاده الاتصال بالمركبه يعني
فقدانها وترجح وشركه ان تكون المركبه قد
تحطمت خلال محاولتها الهبوطه على سطح
القمر يمكنكم متابعه المزيد عن هذا
الموضوع في المقطعيه المرفقي في التعليقات
وصلنا الى ختام ايجازنا الاسبوعي الموعد
يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل بحول الله لما كنتم
طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]